wait I say hey everybody welcome to
stream we're very excited today we got
the start as a critical role the geek
and sundry series and today we're gonna
be cycling out but we've got a sweet
Johnson at Travis William that's right
that's right
here to answer all your questions we're
gonna battle a super smash brothers I
don't think any of us a know anything
about super smash brothers know or play
super smash brothers know it's gonna
have a blind leading the blind leading
the blind
punching in the dark room I do not like
your old school what's up cute TV oh man
oh my god the chats going crazy you guys
are tired but good y'all are so popular
notice y'all so popular photo King
Deacon girl got a great new one I'm
starting off classic I go Mario there we
go guys he's got stashed he's got the
overalls he can fix your toilet a lot of
Kirby a lot of Kirby's personal problem
when you choose your thing now the next
question where do we play who knows all
right well I think now if I'm not
mistaken it's all about knocking
somebody off the edge
oh good right and the more you've
punched somebody the more they get like
tired okay okay so as your percentage
goes up that's bad I think our Center
means like the more percentage of you
being knocked into oblivion
uh-huh so I think that's how it goes
just letting you know don't be my god
don't be more like Kirby the monster
Darth butter says poor mouth wash your
seat that's right math we made spats it
off camera doc you can stick your hand
in there bet all right
stay out of this uh gamers that we're
doing I just hit a button hello nightly
to you says Travis is gonna win this
yeah oh my god there's a Joe oh god
Gopal this looks like a dream I had once
it with some wet dream I don't know what
that says about me it's terrible I
forgot who I was for a second okay wait
what does what alright I think why jumps
hey everyone on the internet say is I do
like a sweet oh I'm getting railed by
somebody throw a Pokeball well don't you
love the thing oh wait oh wait I just
got punched by somebody coming
yeah that'd be great are you team
monster
I am it looks cool thanks Pamela all I'm
doing right now is just becoming a
balloon yes this is okay I'm sorry okay
Kevin you jump with the directional pad
200 you can also jump with it oh maybe I
should be doing that oh my god I'm
getting destroyed I don't know um all
right so wait you guys are down to
comic-con now Josh you said you guys are
doing a live show oh my god Comic Con
yeah well it's more critical role
started a group of a group of us or just
voice actors actors everything general
nerds in West Philadelphia born and
raised on a playground is where you guys
yeah just a bunch of us we just decided
to oh I just fell off the table and this
is also a tactic for me to beat you but
yeah so we sort of playing the Dragons
yes just privately in the home of Travis
and his wife Laura in the home I know
classic D&D
I love it and then some people heard
about it such as Felicia Day perfect
such as you got your Felicia days we
decided to maybe try streaming it on
their twitch network what is this
present thank you go to a press B oh wow
okay blades all right slay so yeah so we
starts streaming it on Twitch on the
geek and sundry and then it just became
hit it's just yeah every Thursday night
we played for like three to four hours
we just make [ __ ] up we have an amazing
storyteller Matthew Mercer's are done
any place like a hundred different NPCs
with voices and mannerisms and all this
[ __ ] and so we were like maybe we should
try a live show so we did a lot what's
the point this guy what's the fight this
guy go go see Pete the computer yeah and
that's not and then it's again it's just
gone crazy from there crazy from there
such an amazing community and what was
it like the first time because you guys
are kind of been doing this like
privately was it like the first time
that people they were streaming people
were watching where you got I mean you
guys are obviously professional actors a
lot of stuff but was it a little nerve
work I was working my mom can drive if
yours can pick up yeah it was a little I
wasn't there for the very first day in
that they stream because I was working
but I know the first day my was that I
was very nervous but yeah I think we all
had a little bit of alcohol as well okay
courage once you get used to like the
random ask cameras that are just sitting
around it's no different than playing in
our living room the sheriff just making
fools of ourselves the live shows little
bit different cuz that everybody's there
laughing at your stupid face right oh my
god yeah is this gonna be your first
luxury have you done that before we had
one was the last week Travis are gonna
died last week what I'm gonna die only
last week I know she's yeah as if his
last week in Los Angeles was like a
tester
Oh
at Gen Con in Indianapolis August 6
Saturday night we're having a live show
Anthony Hall usually going to voice
actor hey man that is that's crazy
does it affect how you play and when you
play in front of a lot are you do do
more daring things who do you want to
like cream or excitement
are you still true to your carrier you
know I don't know I don't know I feel
like it in some ways it does help to
play live because you don't have a lot
of just kind of just sitting there
staring trying to figure out what to do
I mean there's just you have to just go
sure sure just happen me a lot of times
you make rash decisions that are later
you're like why did I do that
I'm so stupid me in life yeah exactly I
think it I mean it's so fun
it's just
are there any now I feel like with live
shows there might be the chance for a
little bit of humiliation so if
something like that happens do you are
you gonna have to get up and do a little
dance
oh no you won because now we can play
yeah I think now we get to play you know
Laura is the voice of Mussina uh yeah
I'm getting out of this Mario there is
starfox I say smarter I get oh and
little Mike little Mac we uh we met the
Creator you know Mario I mean moto is
that is good yeah yeah a couple years
ago and and Conan was like you know why
the mustache you couldn't have but on
this big question like you know was it
because of this and more manly and this
thing there's a plumber and he goes no
it was just because of the pixels we had
to make it look like so literally like
we just had to make sure that people
knew he had a nose and then it looked
like it was a I love it I love
everything
I love Tina by dr. Kelling state who is
the weirdest who's the weirdest I'm on
purple Donkey Kong no green yeah yeah
Green I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go Pokemon character do you guys
play pokemon go I did I do you did
you're covering Kokomo no I did I didn't
play it from the wound but I was like I
gotta know what this is about
you gotta do your research if 14 more
miles is that it's that metric though
that's English how many comments for
right
yeah that's 1600 clozapine miles well
almost 14 it was like 13 something like
oh did you get won't I'm gonna do that
day clearly I had the day off in New
York no you had a lot to do you had a
capture some cocaine yeah what level are
you now I deleted it let me hit there a
buddy boy okay did you get a squirrel
and Bop I got a girl of it a squirrely
boppin home but let's get it yet
get a David Spade that's what I'm
waiting to see here though because
because of the mass of humanity that's
here I'm just waiting to see like the
hordes oh I'm sure it's gonna be it's
gonna be banana have you seen it already
yes it happened cuz I know at one moment
it's either gonna be like a fire a
terrorist attack or somebody why the
legendary Pokemon and everybody just
starts moving
I heard near Petco Stadium there's a ton
I near the Convention Center so must be
a lot of rare ones I think let's gang up
on player shoots what are you oh I'm the
drive that I'm the the dragon guy here's
the thing you know what I have to say
something about dragons okay how they
always like when you're not with their
tail this is a little I have an issue in
on point of order
I don't have order with the dragon I
mean either whip their tails
back and forth yeah wouldn't that hurt I
mean their tails have nerve endings it's
just like what do you do you can't just
whip your tail at something it's like if
you hit somebody in the face it's gonna
hurt yeah I mean my dog has a did your
dog in his tail hurts me really yeah you
guys shouldn't like have battle you guys
shouldn't be fighting what kind of dog
yeah I never want to have a pet that I
can't take in a fight see look at Donkey
Kong he's just above it all he's just
chillin like Donkey Kong is definitely
definitely the worst-smelling
carrot that's right I mean he's green
right it's sweaty there's a lot of fur I
felt out again what am i doing
we are with Travis William and Ashley
Johnson from critical role today you can
go to geek & sundry on or [ __ ] roll calm
airs Thursday nights at 7:00 on Twitch
or X dot Mandy that's my little song for
you guys I made it and they have been
the voice of a ton of amazing character
Ellie last of us travel like what's your
favorite character you done oh man well
I love Roy Mustang in my mind one of my
first ones in my full metal alchemist
days but they do telltale games just
announced the Batman yeah but they're
doing I'm playing Harvey Dent has some
crazy stuff I like them
the very first telltale game I played
was The Walking Dead and I was like okay
what is this like oh choose your
adventure oh my and then immediately
gets crazy oh like right up yeah just
like oh you may have to make terrible
choices
oh holy Moses
oh yes that was gorgeous old horse Groot
I don't even know people are saying
these days I take root I take Gragas
heartbeat ensign what he said exactly
yeah let's I love about your characters
you play a person right and I know you
play by the other p-body switch that
right yeah switch bodies there we go
like vice versa who's gonna be the judge
reinhold she waits it out so I tell
super got pike what's the deal with that
hike is a cleric besides having a name I
wish I had cuz Pike is way cooler than
Mary Nome her family and our ancestors
come from a deep dome so they're a
little Shady
I bet moon show oh man is for that it's
the best you know
it's called grog probably my god yes
what if that was my name because that's
a family brewed now our characters
actually a we combined our backstories
like I was a Goliath mulberry and it was
wandering around the woods with me
peoples I wanted to attack one of her
wonderful will hand and I didn't want to
I fell off the world yeah
and she saved she helped save my father
saved him and so we're sort of an
unlikely pair and best friend slash
almost brother and sister yep and it's
funny because he's huge and my
characters Wolverine
Oh Colossus woman Dennis well sorry
don't yell at me everyone I made a
mistake that is raging right now Lord
it's wrong I don't know if you've
noticed but I have a fireball sword like
I'm just just sort of float around them
I don't think there looks like a great
coffee shop right over there I guess
good good cold brew I have a jet pack
reason white shirt I will say somebody
say Travis Singh Hamilton you know you
want to do it what's that about
I may have gotten a little drunk in a
bar last night it was like a beer and I
was singing Hamilton I satisfied which
isn't even a guy's dog I guess my wife
got the like was super behind the scenes
book so I was reading up oh my girls a
little obsessed we're going to see it oh
man what do you win one of your tickets
next weekend mortgage the house and it
does things to hash tag things we need
videos of you're right we keep getting
it actually keeps throwing us off the
map the little guy it's just oh you're
killing us I feel like I just keep
floating in the air
did you whose nests ah that's it
actually I think you won hey you won I
want you in a back that doesn't seem
fair yeah I was just like pop pop this
is definitely doing something bad to our
brains I can tag that back hey man cam
deck was my horrible uncle that we
killed recently
yeah that's rude and I go I don't I'm
not doing high fives I do tingles so I'm
not so violent there's no fast this
world guys that's what I'm doing oh yeah
just the tingle today what was the
polish George let me have
guess I'm the weasel how many
comic-con's have you guys been to oh
[ __ ] I think this is like what what is
some of the cream
this is your second counter this is you
you guys better win come on Travis - you
are a Jew load up on swag do you like to
collect figures or anything you're gonna
be sneaking around trying to get here so
there's like the annual trip to go dye
shopping and if if you're feeling a
little reckless you may or may not buy a
dice from like a dinosaur bone or a
meteorite wait what okay yeah legit
what's the name of the booth that it
sells it the dice yeah I forget what
it's called we went there last year and
in like a glass case right whenever like
how am I gonna buy what's in the glass
case bottle of booze at a bar you know
two dollars and there was a dice that
was made from a meteorite and one that
was made from the bone Allosaurus
it's like it's like the size of my
thumbnail I mean it's so small you can't
even roll it really well on the table
but it is a lucky dice - yeah you don't
there's no reason to buy it and I never
really worried that'd be like haunted by
the ghost of a dinosaur so then my house
would be just like having dynast creepy
Japanese like you know girl with like
you know the ring you don't want the
Royal dinosaur yeah I don't want that
girl to brush her hair it's not she's a
bit scary just let me have Sheamus near
old dude so by the way that's not
actually it should be birthdays soon
Sheamus I think real
zero that's out there is that such a
tease all right I lost everyone nearly
pretty please okay I guess it's not
really Dino oh man when who zero suit
samus is those kids okay stay on the
ground
do I look at Max or something basically
in what was a color guard we just have
like the flag Oh
Samus shaming I thought it was Sheamus I
thought it was Sheamus to its people to
say shame Sheamus is is this a drunk
Irish flag it's whatever you wanted
sorry sorry I colossal producers asking
what Nintendo voices have you guys done
Nintendo no not yet I think we all made
the other way here's a question have you
guys or are there plans to make like a
comic book of your critical role we've
shown up at our characters have shown up
in a couple of comic books already
oh that's cool rat Queens which was
pretty awesome awesome we're all huge
fans yes there was a comic strip there's
been some Marisha and Alison we're sort
of writing some comic strips last year
awesome and they were rad
there's some there's some fun stuff in
the works that's just so funny coming
out of ya a D&D game that we played
that's great
the live show was like so so cool for us
so we're like alright let's do some art
stuff we're gonna make a card yeah I
mean are you guys a little surprised in
a good way about how popular I got
something where I'm glowing how is it a
hundred and forty percent and now I'm at
zero yeah life is so hard
pimento Wow look at that
you need more Sun bro the dance that's
just rude just saying uh what I do do
NATO do NATO a so what I guess actors
would you love to have on critic role
that you haven't already
oh man we got a list name one name one
William bleh-bleh has two Kamali's okay
actually that's all I did in high school
he's played oceans attorney although it
was rips it wasn't obvious I was a
glitter boy which we'll get into when I
tell us and Liam get out here like we
know our fellow like fantasy nerds like
Colbert or like like we have our like
crazy wish list yeah how'd you be
incredible so funny and Gandhi Lincoln
I'm so glad I bought Colbert for us
Carell Internet reaches his pj's world
explodes from the Arthur I am very slow
I was a glitter boy the Aaron blared
story that's to watch his boom
it's the rope and oh don't don't be
don't be concerned Caesar Augustus
I bet joy Caesar crowd t-shirt probably
be a pretty good guess that critical
role book laughing right very much be
tough probably chalice and probably
speaks Latin house it probably doesn't
really surprise
come get me I'm not coming down there oh
he was going off Oh actually how is
working on blind spot how do you like
that great I love it
New York so that part is sad because I
have to be away from these guys that's
right there we go perfect it's the East
Coast time change yeah that's true but
we make it work
and yeah it's it's foreign spot it's
been it's been great we just started our
second season all right think we have to
say goodbye nice to Travis and Ashley
[Music]
please welcome li mo bright bye-bye Oh
tickles tickles
I forgot I broke my own rule I'll rule
Liam O'Brien everybody leave um Ryan
hello Melissa Jett is it Jeff Jaffe
Jaffe yeah that's the coolest thing
that's usually the owner Erin Blair
either bless you on the other side of
that name they throws people to tell us
so tell us it right oh please we got
that nail your name please I'm an open
book
my heart is open guys any questions yeah
it's probably promotion yeah I should
it's getting one
all right we shot here all right so if
you guys played super special a long
time yeah all right I am learning first
way you're gonna want to hit hey that's
good I'm going for I'm going for chic
over here because my head I need to be
wearing more hats because the top of my
head is sunburned so that's what I'm
taking my there's no hair under that
there's no it's actually just my open
skull exactly the height Alison kick his
butt you didn't specify whose butt so
I'm gonna say kick Liam's but that's
right guys welcome how many Comic Cons
have you been to so far you dare I ask
awesome rate for me I might be pushing
20 I don't know okay okay let's see why
why jumps job why jokes also I think you
can push up to Joe let's see here a I
know does a dozen I think a light attack
V does a heavy attack this makes no
sense
yeah it's crazy I just hit buttons and
try to just have this not hurt my brain
in her tonight no I am there I am kicks
him Ashley and how did I even win the
last Smash Brothers tournament our
people are asking about Conan like
khottabych yeah there's no way I can
leave this room without telling you oh
no no internet with burned down this are
glorious is dungeon master Matthew
Mercer was out of town a little while
ago get my ass kicked so I can focus on
the story yeah and we thought you know
in the past we've done like party games
or Q&A is just a pastime because nobody
can really live up to man oh wow he's
that good those are big shoes he is that
good well I still play at the last
second and all of us work at Warner
Brothers a lot perfect wait I used the
Dungeons & Dragons rule system but I set
it in one of the ADR rooms
Warner Brothers awesome and brought in
and monsters and had our design Travis
towels and salmon Borah plague Travis
Laura Sam and Allison yeah no idea where
I am on the screen there was slime and
then eventually it ended in a hellscape
with the tower still standing
oh my god I'm flying above the tower was
a skeletal horse which is an undead
wizard but in this game since we were on
the Warner Brothers lot I was owning
perfect
so his normal it was just normal you
just said normal Cody yes and just our
office it's a northbound ski that's what
they call our office and these fine
actors got into a battle and ripped his
face off and yes well done guys time
continued well there was nothing to be
done and they turned on each other real
yeah that's Conan has that effect on
people
yeah that effective little Mac oh man
behold the power of cardio look at look
at one of those what are these these are
those triceps he's got their eyes yeah
Israel oh you know may-maybe yeah B star
looks which super smash character would
you want to voice that's a great
question let's also ask the head to
let's see all right I know oh it doesn't
make any sense
oh wait we gotta fight this foe first of
all who is a little bit wait tell us
what did you play it was a little man
Lauren you got now you gotta fight the
new girls yeah all right it's stupid
Abel if dumb wings you're talking about
yeah I hate I hate characters with wings
let me just protect me wait pointable
quite a border Oh God
we want to hear that right I just got
wings in our game Oh Mike really yeah
okay well here's the thing black
actually question for you like wing and
Caractacus a lot like that a brand new
really yes wait how can you sit in a
chair is it just always stools his look
look I don't have a great core I'm just
gonna be honest sorry it's the Internet
me to be honest I sitting up I like the
lean against things and it would be it
would suck if I'm constantly like I
think mine kind of shrink back into my
back what I'm not using this you can
sort of curve them into sort of a
new-age chair can you get them ourselves
great a second detailing you it's like
you have one it's like one of those
canes that turns into a stool you've
always got a chair oh yeah they curve
into like a gaming oh oh that's e curve
for your back it's great
Nemo prize oh that is that's the best
explanation I've ever heard I am well he
was doing the talk and I was I was
having problems with uh yeah yeah what
flavor is up it's actually it's NAS
berry Oh fantastic
and what does it taste like um
snozzberry fantastic huh which is you
know but not real snozzberry it's that
artificial stars bear oh yes well it's
you sugary little sugary and there's
about five or six minutes where you will
drop to the ground and see them seen
okay fine
it's got a 7-eleven Slurpee yeah and
then and then like a demon horde pulls
you in the hell and you spend eternity
there until you come back out so it's
kind of like almost no name yet yeah
courtesy 6:24 xc6 part of the MKULTRA
program they developed so we talked
about this with Travis Ashley but let's
talk about this live show you guys are
doing yeah very exciting was that is
that why oh wow I'm not gonna be there
I'm still very like mottier back sorry
yeah but the live show that we have was
great but all theater nerds - so getting
that that energy it's like surfing oh my
god
you guys are gonna get spoiled now
you're gonna have to have like a it
turned it into a live show it's I gotta
say it's apples and orange
it gets to you it gets to you we like
our intimacy and our mission for being
able to 60 episodes zero payments do you
guys actually this is kind of I will say
do you guys have a little superstitions
of you before you roll dice for 10
minutes before every episode that's not
true is that true oh my god see if you
bought the dinosaur died so you wouldn't
have to charge us Wow I always use the
same guy I have the meteorite died oh
you do I use oh my god gave Han it's
tiny it could kill you if I throw it at
you oh my god it is not not of this
earth it does treat me good it's hard to
see though how interesting I have a I
have a I'm uprooted one from shapeways
that I love at a shake weight great dive
I have a shake weight the Golden Snitch
yeah you can actually buy it on check
boys oh you should all battle twenties
all day long there actually is a website
where they've counted it's kind of
terror wow that's a crazy oh my god yes
I played all during high school and then
a little bit of rips getting any rips
getting any
vampire the masquerade no then I know we
stuff do we do a lot of the expansion
stuff but it was crazy like I can
realize before I started playing how
serious it gets like I was like oh this
is gonna be really fun cut to like week
three and I'm like sweating like oh my
god I'm gonna get killed I'm gonna get
killed and this is awful and people even
and this is kind of bad to say there are
a couple fights on the parking lot
that's right that's right um like
somebody are so lucky they didn't have
iPhones oh my god oh well yeah we gotta
we had our own room at Denny's they put
us in this back room so we had our own
room it was amazing dude it was amazing
it was amazing we do suffer a little bit
of anxiety
thanks for yeah it's but I will say like
if people who've never played it kind of
done through the Dragons or anything you
know you spend a lot of time crafting
your character and and over the weeks
and months you go through a lot of this
character and it does truly get very
emotional you have a lot of invested in
this character Finn tears on the show oh
yeah I'm sure
yeah I'm sure absolutely this one over
here died before our show started and we
were all beside ourselves crying into
the brief that's the same yeah oh I love
that yeah it's a bit counterintuitive I
love to sew stranger things you haven't
seen it what are you doing for life but
also it's a Netflix series I think it
just came out like two weeks ago by the
duffer brothers and it's set in the 80s
it's like a legitimate child of Steven
Spielberg and Stephen King it really
feels like it could be like part of an
amazing stories or something I did two
episodes I make stories a weird laying
out that's mine no you're like I love
that show oh my god wait which episode
oh the body switch episode yeah and then
the ghost the in the house trying to
kick out the the creepy people that's
insane Wow that's unbelievable
Wow before I dye my hair I used to work
[Laughter]
and it's a Netflix series and it's
really great and it's got feels like
yeah like all the greats like 80s kind
of horror creepy fantasy series slasher
movies there's like it feels like like
even like the logo feels like John
Carpenter watch when odor riders a mom
and it's kind of about these kids and
there's you know Matthew Modine is like
a government kind of guy you don't
really know what's going on I'm sure
cries weakly said somebody there were
like legit tears you exude here dad it
was like it was it was intense by the
way you're asking us about dream players
we obviously want to come to you and
play with you in Conan oh my gosh yeah
that would be fantastic
oh yeah like oh how I get me in the back
oh yeah yeah we would love I tried to do
some kind of a before the tabletop will
got that serious start yeah an idea to
do like and I was like are you doing it
it's so much better you need to sample
our minds yeah it's it's pure it's pure
uncut I'm oh my god no it was like
they've been diesel did a brief thing
with us and I saw that that was
fantastic it's great he's a good friend
of ours okay hey
oh yeah oh my god yeah that would be
super fun oh wait so tell us wait so you
play per seat oh I play person so tell
us about person he I'm my shorthand for
him and I love this just is that he's
just the worst person
oh he's me for he's he's he's he's a
Tyrion Lannister okay like he always
thinks he's the smartest person in the
room
great he's privileged
and awful privilege it is well aware
that he's probably terrible but really
doesn't like to think about it too much
he's actually he's a gunslinger which is
a little weird he's bass because we
started in a different system oh okay
been to the gun so he invented in D&D
he's the only person who has a gun
because he invented the gun
oh that's cool and so he's kind of this
weird little mad inventor running around
the traditional fantasy world of
Dungeons & Dragons oh my god that's
awesome feels really awful for yeah it's
gonna be fun though to step into a
character like oh he's if you kind of
can get out all the worst who you're if
you're angry or whatever like during the
week then you get then you can unpack
man well yeah he said oh he's got a lot
of my like 13 year old best intentions
yeah sure there we go he's very he's
like a high fantasy Whovian James Bond
Wow and Liam how do you say your
character's name it's it's you just say
back Sat okay there we go that's my
first respects Laura plays my twin
sister also we share the same birthday
in real life so we decided to do the
same thing oh there you go
I like how realities in forming before
being a game more than you know although
I went pallid and recently because I
found God accidentally dabble you dabble
I love it
that's awesome and we worry about the
game too much beyond was healthy yeah
how much talking is done and how much
shiitake is done outside of playing
quite a bit like we play off each other
pretty well and it's so it's kinda we
don't plan anything everything just
right cuz because we wouldn't wouldn't
make such terrible decisions and right
right it would seems to be going a lot
smoother yeah much like the game we're
playing right now right exactly
yeah if there's like if in the game for
us to talk to each other we do and say
you tear the bottle cap and on the stick
you up the left side of go for right
yeah and that usually lasts 20 minutes
before all those plans yeah we've had
we've had specific text chains or like
Google talks because somebody is not
available and so they're like you
weren't in the room when we were
planning so you can't be part of the
plan guys if you could turn even giant
mouth I basically imagine that would I'm
like they're here I hear pac-man kind of
in here I wanna power what are you gonna
do right I hear like I hear that I hear
that actually specifically the guy who
runs the dime diner in the movie I
accuse my parents which is like one of
my favorite mst3k operas oh my god I've
ever have a cheeseburger want to tell me
about your problems what do i Kostas is
Jonah rice taking over mst3k great did
you mean it to me he's like freaking out
it's gonna be and I can't wait oh my god
yeah he's over the moon
I love like like I wouldn't get the
cheese sticks kid no too bad for your
heart it puts it out like being your
king look at him he's yellow he smokes
yeah he's got some kind of look up fake
happy is that's exactly the way hey hey
turn around slow up oh my god you're
awful well you've right why don't you
turn nothing happens you just big round
the ball it's all the same I'm just
imagining a greninja with your big
tongue yeah
so you do it oh my god I heard think I
thought of the worst thing to say I
apologize the Internet you gotta put on
the bow otherwise I don't know which
side is which it's ridiculous I'm gonna
be this Agron ninja going big tongue
what's the thing now not choosing people
for some reason I don't know be the
night
speaking about talking about stranger
things is there what show would you guys
like to see come back like did you grow
for the certain show like what like in
terms of influences it's now like you
know they're kind of doing a lot of
reboots I mean they've redone Texas
changed I've asked her 50,000 because if
you say it three times then it happens
to the Beetlejuice rule robots gobots no
no no no no I would like to see he-man
revisited and done right whoa all right
done right what do you mean sup who
would explain done right not
specifically to sell toys alone right
maybe there'd be some I got a weird one
this yeah one of my friends used to
write for a law and order and apparently
a lot of the law and order writers also
wrote GI Joe and GI Joe I just said like
literally it was like what toy I'm sorry
I'm gonna ruin your childhood like
alright we got a new you know whatever
we gotta sell more Zartan so put him in
this week is really noisy little tiny
twenty minutes long GI Joe cartoon that
Warren Ellis wrote that's amazing whoa
it's out there what it's amazing it does
that it contain the multiverse and the
stack of you can snowflake it's so good
it's like it's blowing everyone's fine
they look like weird it were like you're
an absolute it's like do you guys you're
absolutely ready look at the end no but
like like Cobras like scary it's really
cool oh cool they kill people I hear
this guy I when she kicks up though
she's showing a lot of leg I'm not sure
this is good for a child this is our
home yeah I would love to see defenders
of the earth come back as a cartoon who
don't record defenders of the earth oh
all right it was it was eternity yeah
antim it was the Phantom Ming the
Merciless like all like the classic left
Flash Gordon Oh Lothar like all fight
make sure this was an awesome dream you
had no this was a totally like it was a
it was a hanna-barbera animated action
show god that's awesome yeah for
licensing exists like no well they're
all plaid like Mickey Mouse's in there
freaking Ronald Reagan it was it was
jelly bean all the classic public to
main characters and all wipe them all on
the team it's really and it was George
Washington weirdly oh why not why not
[ __ ] I yeah oh yeah they remember
this one oh man Drake man Drake of the
vision drug dealer I think paired by
waffles just sing drug dealer to say
yeah I think I got the first I was so
proud as a kid I got the first Castle
Grayskull they sold it Sears sure yeah
you're from Franklin right there we go I
do my research
hey hey hey Ann Arbor ace deuce ace
deuce kill it but too dumb to go to U of
M so I went to Michigan State great
farms like too bad I wasn't a better
David by the way we have a we had maybe
we still have a keep in our game and
understand dragon call Paul Grayskull
Freeman yes and always grace well
Grayskull Grayskull
oh yeah maybe it's better still
Grayskull I was addicted to a Japanese /
French production of a show called
cities of cities of gold mysterious goal
oh that was amazing Spaniards and space
aliens robotic oh so good amazing just
like all right what's the coolest [ __ ]
it exists all right let's just put all
in one show it was it was a double every
year was that in Spartacus in some
beneath the sea was it it's like Girl
Talk
love Girl Talk GT bring it back GT I
watched Jimmy mashup master just make a
Jem and the Holograms like a live-action
right they know sorry sorry no we're
pretending that yeah sorry to bring down
the room everybody I think I may have
kick-started a fan film I was a big fan
of the Monchichi monkeys got Shaunie out
let me try the tails talking about I
wanna see Andy Serkis to the haunt Ichi
one of my friends growing up was a huge
shirttails and when she chose intel's
awesome she was like nuts in the
bathroom yeah that's a little weird it's
like I have a two-year-old that to you
and now like kids and I don't know if it
was just cuz when we were kids we were
too dumb to realize that it was just
mindless crazy but the shows now are so
insane it's just like they've cranked it
up to 11 it's like it's an acid trip
it's like there's this one show called
blaze which is like they're all monster
trucks that talk but it's not like cars
were like the windshield is like the
eyes and it looks kind of friendly it's
like the grille is two teeth and it's
all it's like hey oh my god it's
horrifying
also if you watch Thomas the Thomas the
whatever the the train engine it's also
very dark but there's one more like
their chorus and like Boris doesn't pull
enough weight and they literally wall
him up in a tunnel and just like see you
later for it it's crazy it's crazy oh my
god they wall him up like Edgar Allan
Poe style forget about it yeah the Cask
of Thomas what it's all done with that
really happy like and then they sing a
song as they drive away and he's just
banging his head his face trying to you
know God exactly I just want a whole
episode where they all deserve they have
no arms
[ __ ] [ __ ] just scream
Thomas scared yeah Thomas is so dark
thank you for backing me up the Cask of
Amontillado I'm guessing that - thomas
the train engine reference it might be
the episode might be the Act could be I
love the Internet
exactly exactly oh my god this is really
intense and you wouldn't be oh you
wouldn't leave the tunnel that's why
they want him up in there that's fine
that's a terrible thing to take this
somebody with anxiety I know Adventure
Time is also kind of dark but Adventure
Time knows what they're doing and that's
not I would say Adventure Time is not
really if every experience I've had with
people who make a children's cartoons
leads me to believe it's all in tension
oh absolutely that's it I feel like
that's the only way that they can kind
of go through their day what's that
thing I heard that the guys who make
Sesame Street for the wrap party they
have much cocaine yeah so much cocaine
and they also do like a crazy like a
like a weird sexual play with the
puppets sorry
killing killing childhoods one child at
a time oh no oh no or nineties x-men it
was great
why do they call him big yeah Adventure
Time is amazing bacon pancakes makin
bacon pancakes guys with Liam O'Brien
and Tallis and Jaffe from critical role
you can see them every Thursday nights
on Twitch at 7:00 playing critical role
also geek and sundry calm and crit roll
dot-com and Liam has a die made out of a
meteorite and I'm pretty sure it's an
alien egg that's gonna hatch it like
fell from the sky and landed as a 20 in
my left eye socket and I never lost and
all the power in the city went out at
the same time and then there were weird
plants that appear near I win every game
of that's true good point
you're gonna get your like hold on alien
[Applause]
that's right that's a thing wait now
Liam you play you totally played a lot
of evil geniuses right that's what your
Wikipedia says I'm okay
there's
mortars the Lord of the Rings game on
there we go there we go Oh Ravens
where's hands a little bit big one and
there we go there we go what is your
what is your inspiration in other pop
culture do you have evil geniuses you
look up to geez man who's the gonna
think of the words trying to stay away
from politics exactly yeah I think we
all hate rustlers oh yeah /ps did you
yeah
look volcano politics about a lot of
funny things to say after oh no stream
is on YouTube by the way it's already
all over Trump so it doesn't mom
geniuses dr. Horrible's great Oh dr.
arbol is amazing I think I hope they do
more dr. Horrible's that house I know
the house it's still sitting there it
hasn't changed is that you at all yeah
oh man I mean if you go back as a
fantasy nerd I was way in a dragon Lance
I was a kid regular you know I've heard
of it I don't know dragon it was it was
a fantasy world based off of D&D
campaigns that are they made novels and
all and a cartoon and there was a
character in that called based Lincoln
started as a neutral character but got
worse as time went on like so we all
know don't we all yeah I'm getting
better I'm learning things I'm doing
nice things for people what is it I was
just I just made you I've just made your
sister a Baroness haha nicee wait is
that you can visit so many things that's
gross what I just made your sister a
Baroness
come on daddy's keep it clean keep it
clean that's code he says after he
swears that that I swear a thousand
times over yeah new nuts
god damn be that group Oh somebody just
bought a dragon lands coming for their
wife it's said it's people riding
dragons it's awesome that's such a
ridiculous board game that I have to
this seems unfair a giant thing of lava
lava is always kind of unfair I agree no
I'm trying to wish you away with I don't
know who I picked I just want to sing
let it go socio so she could feel smug
in the face of peasants is that yeah
that was
feel smug in the face of Gentry actually
I let you just to make people it just
makes our she was already smoking no I
feel a little bad about it mattress like
I may have created that's frigging
kender somebody said into this critical
roles yeah I feel left out it is it is I
will say if we're trying to watch time
you guys just ID'd your 60th episode
yeah weekend there's over 200 hours of
us rolling that is amazing there's no
rocks the morons at this point and I'm
gonna I'm gonna binge-watch them all
this week before I leave comic people do
I'm good I'm gonna have it spent to
Maxim I'm gonna have to set up like four
screens and just kind of play get
messages constantly if people saying oh
man I just took two weeks to binge watch
the whole show you say 100 hours awesome
what a compliment wow that's pretty
flattering it's uh yeah and it's I mean
like oh jeez there are places where you
can hop on but there's in there we have
a back a little bit of a back story
video okay okay ten minutes okay like
you can yeah like there's some if you
want to pop into the newest arc you can
do that but you're gonna be a little
confused so yeah band like we have some
are Clark moments we're like the story
sort of it doesn't quite reset but it's
like spider-man you kind of sure yeah
yeah exactly there's there's a time see
that where the carousel slows down long
enough eats time you can jump on at that
point we should videos just for like
white stone like I mean I feel like I
follow
I followed lost which was super
confusing towards the end so I feel like
I could probably we are way more linear
yeah see there we go exactly is there by
the way here's couple question is there
any plans at any future point if you
guys decide to kind of like end or move
on its are you guys gonna try to wrap it
up with like a double wedding or
something like friends like is there
been any talk of see house where Audrey
perfect it's all the dream more like yes
really
we all wake up and I kill you know yeah
the crazy 88 but it's just me yeah new
[ __ ] has a new foe has appeared which is
what I say when I walk into a bar
exactly guys oh my God we're almost out
of time by the way so if you have any
more questions for Thomas Jaffe or Liam
O'Brien you want to pitch it to me try
to play one of all of us yeah come on
let's I think we do what's all a snow
globe and mats letting her open you
actually you got attempt that would be
just don't know who's fighting for our
honor right now yeah I'm ready we're
gonna get one massive battle here wait
hold on all right let me go back all
right do we have a fourth we get oh we
do we have another fourth we have
another all right so somebody take my
keys which player my I'm three okay I'm
five I'm gonna play Marth because I feel
like that's my spirit name is Mars
Oh something said literally the best
people on the internet right here okay
so like here like figure out grog Percy
fighting back deathmatch flattery or to
it you moderately far I'll tell you what
that is prepare to meet though I don't
mean like I'm ready everybody here we go
random row right no how do we do rent
wears purple
get it pike someone said this is a
critical role who's the Wii Fit trainer
actually I hate Pilates so I'm coming
after you no mercy prepare for my mikaze
Pikachu for the women I don't even know
who I am I mean like you got on the
Internet all right I got the big tape of
the more you're more to my pike the old
sticks this was crazy my life you a
comedy over battle pac-man for the first
two minutes of this and then I realized
I keep falling off yeah she does yoga
she makes us all feel bad about our
bodies bodies like look at this look at
this look at this look at this oh it's
night time a scary feeling my Pikachu
Pikachu just took a dump
oh no my god morph I don't know how to
oh I don't know how to vice posted more
my strategy is to keep falling off
why is jump and then a and B are punches
aggressive yoga oh that's the week they
try its aggressive yoga its I am the
Serena star yeah Pikachu is not nothing
around by the way I wrote it over in
this whole thing here we go
Pikachu's all the business oh here we
come on Mars come on Pikachu what you
got sword fight oh yeah okay okay I'm
coming back I'm coming back oh come over
oh oh but I felt you know in games and
movies it's so easy to grab onto a Ledge
in real life they feel like your fingers
would just get ripped oh yeah oh yeah
know that point of order your fingers
are going up top
yeah like make the drink an uncharted
literally the most fit human on them oh
my god his fingers are so strong oh I
fell he's entirely titania green yeah
no let me pair my brother didn't work
hey kind of [ __ ]
oh my god well thank you guys Travis
William Ashley Johnson thank you so much
critic Rick Rolled calm everybody calm
Thursday night's seven and see these
guys live when they do their live show
if you're here in San Diego which is
when o gentle August 6 we'll put up a
lace will put up a link follow them good
luck in live show and I see these guys
rock comic-con and say hi
[Applause]
[Music]
you